Today we  have this story for you about cars-- American cars. And like most stories about American cars lately, it's more tragedy than comedy, though there is some comedy in there, too. It's the story of a factory in California that captures pretty much everything that's gone wrong in the American car business in the last 30 years. And at the heart of the story is the question, why are American cars still not as good as foreign cars?
今天我们为您带来这个关于汽车的故事——美国汽车。和最近大多数关于美国汽车的故事一样，与其说它是喜剧，不如说它更像是一场悲剧，尽管其中也有一些喜剧成分。这是一个关于加州一家工厂的故事，它几乎涵盖了过去30年里美国汽车业出现的所有问题。故事的核心在于一个问题：为什么美国汽车仍然不如外国汽车？
Come with me for just a half minute to the Detroit Auto Show, OK? David Champion is one of the umpires who calls strikes and fouls in the car business. He's the senior director of Consumer Reports auto test division. He says that Ford has actually been improving for the last six or seven years, but Chrysler's still in the dumps, the worst of all the car makers they study, and as for America's biggest car maker, GM?
和我一起花半分钟时间去看看底特律车展，好吗？David Champion是汽车行业的裁判之一，负责评判优劣。他是《消费者报告》汽车测试部门的高级主管。他说，福特在过去六七年里确实有所进步，但克莱斯勒仍处于低谷，是他们所研究的所有汽车制造商中最差的一家；至于美国最大的汽车制造商通用汽车（GM）呢？
The big Achilles' heel with GM is their reliability. You look at things like the Cadillac CTS-- a fabulous car, I'd take a CTS over a BMW or a Mercedes any day. But unfortunately, the CTS has been poor for reliability since it was redesigned in 2007. So they still quite haven't got it.
通用汽车最大的致命弱点是其可靠性。你看看凯迪拉克CTS之类的车——那是一辆非常棒的车，我随时都会选CTS而不是宝马或奔驰。但遗憾的是，自2007年重新设计以来，CTS的可靠性一直很差。所以他们还是没有掌握好精髓。
Why hasn't GM got it yet? It's not like this reliability problem just snuck up on them. It's been nearly 50 years since it started losing market share-- 50 years since it began the slide from holding over half the US car market, back in the '60s, to just 22% today. Here's an amazing fact. Even after Toyota's recent disaster with suddenly accelerating cars that killed possibly 52 people, Consumer Reports came out with new ratings just this month and it still rates Toyota as more reliable than all the American car makers.
为什么通用汽车还没掌握好？这并不是说可靠性问题突然袭击了他们。距离通用汽车市场份额开始流失已经过去近50年了——从60年代占据美国一半以上的汽车市场，到今天仅剩22%，下滑之路已经走了50年。这里有一个惊人的事实：即使在丰田最近因汽车突然加速导致可能52人死亡的灾难之后，《消费者报告》在本月发布的新评级中，仍将丰田评为比所有美国汽车制造商更可靠。
That's because the ratings are based on overall dependability-- the likelihood of whether you'll have a problem with your Toyota, and mostly, they are still very reliable cars. In fact, the top three automakers in the most recent Consumer Reports survey are all Japanese-- Toyota is number three-- and the top 10 are all foreign.
这是因为评级基于整体的可靠性——即你的丰田车出现问题的可能性，而且大部分情况下，它们依然是非常可靠的汽车。事实上，在最近的《消费者报告》调查中，排名前三的汽车制造商全是日本公司——丰田排名第三——而且前十名全部是外国品牌。
Why is it taking so long for Detroit to figure out how to make a car as good as the Japanese? Well, there's some very interesting answers to that question, and all of them can be found right here-- at a car plant in Fremont, California, called NUMMI. NUMMI stands for New United Motor Manufacturing Incorporated.
为什么底特律花了这么长时间才弄清楚如何制造出像日本车一样好的汽车？嗯，关于这个问题有一些非常有趣的答案，而所有答案都可以在这里找到——加州弗里蒙特的一家名为NUMMI的汽车工厂。NUMMI代表“新联合汽车制造公司”（New United Motor Manufacturing Incorporated）。
A modern car plant, by the way, sounds a lot like a casino. The automated gear plays little songs to let you know that it's running. Driver-less robot carts glide up and down the aisles, like R2D2, delivering doors and other parts. Their song is supposed to warn you that they're coming. The story of this factory is a famous one among car people-- it's taught at business schools.
顺便说一句，现代汽车工厂听起来很像赌场。自动化设备会播放小曲儿来让你知道它正在运行。无人驾驶的机器人小车像R2D2一样在过道里滑行，运送车门和其他零件。它们的歌声是为了提醒你它们要过来了。这家工厂的故事在汽车圈非常出名——它被商学院当作案例教学。
NUMMI was opened in 1984 by GM and Toyota together, who decided this would be a place that they would build cars with each other. If it seems strange to you that two competitors would do this, it seemed strange at the time, also. A headline in Car and Driver about the partnership read, "Hell Freezes Over." But both companies had their reasons-- we'll get into that.
NUMMI由通用和丰田在1984年共同创办，他们决定在这里共同生产汽车。如果两个竞争对手这样做让你觉得奇怪，当时的人们也觉得奇怪。《名车志》（Car and Driver）关于这次合作的一篇头条文章写道：“地狱结冰了”（即“太阳打西边出来了”）。但两家公司都有各自的理由——我们稍后会讲到。
At NUMMI, Toyota showed GM all its secrets-- exactly how it made some of the best built, most reliable cars in the world back then. GM hoped to take these lessons from NUMMI and carry them into all their other plants, all over the country, and all over the world. And then, well, that didn't go so well, and here we are today. GM went bankrupt. US taxpayers-- you and I-- bailed them out for $50 billion.
在NUMMI，丰田向通用展示了它所有的秘密——准确地展示了它在当时是如何制造出世界上最出色、最可靠的汽车的。通用希望从NUMMI汲取这些教训，并将其推广到全国乃至全球的所有工厂。结果嘛，事情进展得并不顺利，于是就有了今天的局面。通用破产了。美国纳税人——你和我——花了500亿美元救助了他们。
And next week, the NUMMI car plant, the one that seemed like it might be able to teach American car makers how to catch up to their competitors, is going to stop making cars. It's happening, no joke, on April Fools' Day. Today we have a special story for you. We are devoting our entire show to it.
下周，NUMMI汽车工厂——这家似乎有能力教导美国汽车制造商如何追赶竞争对手的工厂——将停止生产汽车。这发生在愚人节，一点也不开玩笑。今天我们为您准备了一个特别报道。我们将整期节目都献给它。
For the last couple months, NPR's automotive correspondent, Frank Langfitt and one of our producers, Brian Reed, have been traveling around the country talking to GM workers and managers about what happened at NUMMI, and especially about what went wrong at GM that it had so much trouble for so long adopting the techniques it learned over a quarter century ago.
在过去几个月里，美国国家公共电台（NPR）的汽车记者Frank Langfitt和我们的制作人Brian Reed一直在全国各地奔走，采访通用汽车的工人和经理，探讨NUMMI到底发生了什么，特别是通用汽车在采用了四分之一世纪前学到的技术后，为什么仍有如此多的麻烦。
General Motors and the UAW are secretive cultures, but as you'll hear, people were blunt when they talked to Frank-- blunt in a way that you rarely hear with auto executives and UAW reps when they're being interviewed by the press. Act one of our show is about the rise of NUMMI, act two is about what prevented GM from learning from NUMMI.
通用汽车和全美汽车工人联合会（UAW）的文化非常封闭，但正如你将听到的，当人们和Frank交谈时，他们言辞直率——这种直率在汽车高管和工会代表接受媒体采访时是很少见的。我们节目的第一幕是关于NUMMI的崛起，第二幕是关于是什么阻碍了通用汽车从NUMMI那里学到东西。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Our show today produced with our colleagues at NPR News. And now it is my pleasure to turn the story over to NPR automotive correspondent, Frank Langfitt.
节目来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《This American Life》，由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。我是Ira Glass。今天的节目是与我们在NPR新闻的同事共同制作的。现在，我很荣幸将话筒交给NPR汽车记者Frank Langfitt。
When NUMMI was conceived, General Motors was far and away the world's largest car company. Its US market share was seven times that of Toyota. But each company had a problem that the other company could help them solve. On GM's side, the problem was small cars. Under government emissions guidelines, General Motors had to build them, but they'd always lost money for GM, and they were lousy quality. So Toyota suggested a joint venture that offered two things. First, Toyota would build a quality small car for GM-- one that would finally turn a profit.
当NUMMI构想出来时，通用汽车毫无疑问是全球最大的汽车公司。其美国市场份额是丰田的七倍。但每家公司都有对方可以帮忙解决的问题。通用汽车的问题是小型车。根据政府的排放准则，通用汽车必须生产它们，但这些车总是让通用赔钱，而且质量很烂。于是丰田建议成立一家合资企业，提供两样东西：首先，丰田将为通用生产一种高质量的小型车——一种最终能盈利的汽车。
And the second thing was, we have this thing called the Toyota production system, and it produces the quality you see. We can teach you the Toyota production system.
第二点是，我们有某种被称为“丰田生产系统”的东西，它造就了你所看到的质量。我们可以教你这个系统。
Jeffrey Liker is a professor of industrial engineering at the University of Michigan. He wrote The Toyota Way, and he's been studying Japanese auto manufacturing-- including NUMMI-- since the 1980s. He says even though Toyota was offering GM something quite remarkable-- to teach a competitor its secrets, to show them exactly how Toyota achieved such phenomenal reliability-- GM wasn't that interested.
Jeffrey Liker是密歇根大学的工业工程教授。他撰写了《丰田模式》（The Toyota Way），自80年代以来一直研究日本汽车制造业，包括NUMMI。他说，尽管丰田提供给通用的东西非常了不起——教导竞争对手自己的秘密，准确展示丰田是如何实现如此惊人可靠性的——但通用并不是那么感兴趣。
Some people in GM I think had some foresight to realize this is important. I think for many of the senior leaders, it was more, OK, well, maybe I'll learn something, maybe I won't, but it won't hurt.
我认为通用内部的一些人有远见，意识到这很重要。但对许多高层领导来说，心态更多是：好吧，也许我能学到点什么，也许学不到，但反正也没什么坏处。
Why wouldn't they be really interested in the Toyota production system, because at that point, wasn't Toyota building higher quality cars?
为什么他们对丰田生产系统没有表现出真正兴趣？因为那时候，丰田不是已经在制造更高质量的汽车了吗？
Toyota was building higher quality cars. I'm not sure it was 100% accepted at that time by senior management that Japanese quality was really better.
丰田确实在制造更高质量的汽车。我不确定当时高级管理层是否100%接受日本的质量确实更好这一事实。
Why?
为什么？
I think there was pride and defensiveness. I'm proud because I'm the biggest automaker in the world, I've been the best, I've dominated the market. You can't teach me anything, you little Japanese company.
我觉得是骄傲和自我防卫。我骄傲是因为我是全球最大的汽车制造商，我一直是最棒的，我统治了市场。你这个小小的日本公司，能教我什么？
I'm John Shook. Toyota in Toyota City was completely Japanese when I joined them. I was the first non Japanese to join them as a regular employee in Toyota City.
我是John Shook。我加入丰田时，丰田市的丰田公司完全是日本人的天下。我是第一个以正式员工身份加入丰田市的非日本人。
John Shook moved to Japan in the early 1980s because of his fascination with Japanese management techniques. He read books about them back home in east Tennessee. And he decided to fly halfway around the globe, learn to speak the language, and hunt for a job with the biggest Japanese company that would have him. Toyota hired him to train American workers in the joint venture.
John Shook在80年代初移居日本，因为他对日本的管理技术着迷。他在家乡东田纳西州读过相关的书。他决定飞越半个地球，学习语言，并寻找机会加入那家愿意接纳他的最大的日本公司。丰田雇佣他来培训这家合资企业里的美国工人。
Now, here was the problem that pushed Toyota into the deal. They needed to learn how to build cars in America. For years, the Japanese had been winning away customers from Detroit, and the US Congress was threatening to restrict car imports. Toyota could avoid that by making cars in the US. But they wanted a partner. Here's John Shook.
现在，这就是促使丰田达成这笔交易的问题所在。他们需要学习如何在美国制造汽车。多年来，日本人一直在从底特律手中赢得客户，美国国会威胁要限制汽车进口。丰田可以通过在美国本土制造来规避这一点。但他们想要一个合作伙伴。这就是John Shook的讲述。
Toyota was looking specifically for things they could learn. How can we work with American workers? How can we make sure that our management system can work in North America? And they'd been pretty happy just producing in Toyota City, doing a very good job, and the idea of actually taking their system and producing outside of Toyota City was scary to them.
丰田专门寻找他们可以学习的东西。我们该如何与美国工人合作？我们如何确保我们的管理系统能在北美运作？他们原本在丰田市生产就很满足，做得也很好，而真正将他们的系统带出丰田市去生产，这让他们感到害怕。
Toyota was right to be scared. Compared to Japan, where auto workers and management worked together, labor relations in America were more like war. And at the GM plant in Fremont, it felt at times like hand to hand combat.
丰田感到害怕是正确的。相比于工人和管理层共同协作的日本，美国的劳资关系更像是一场战争。而在弗里蒙特的通用工厂，有时感觉就像肉搏战。
A former running back from the University of Arkansas named Bruce Lee ran the western region for the United Auto Workers, and was in charge of the Fremont Union Local 1364. Now normally, somebody like Bruce Lee is supposed to defend his union members no matter what. But even he says they were awful.
一位名叫Bruce Lee的前阿肯色大学跑卫负责全美汽车工人联合会的西部地区，并管理着弗里蒙特分会1364。通常，像Bruce Lee这样的人无论如何都要捍卫工会成员。但即使是他也承认他们确实很糟糕。
It was considered the worst workforce in the automobile industry in the United States. And it was a reputation that was well earned. Everything was a fight. They spent more time on grievances and on things like that than they did on producing cars. They had strikes all the time. It was just chaos constantly.
它被认为是美国汽车工业中最糟糕的劳动力队伍。这种名声是实至名归的。什么事都要争吵。他们花在申诉和类似事情上的时间比生产汽车的时间还多。他们总是罢工。简直是一片混乱。
The Fremont, California plant for General Motors was bad by GM standards, and GM's average was bad by Toyota standards, so this is the worst among the bad mediocre plants in GM.
加州弗里蒙特的通用工厂按通用标准算很差，而通用的平均水平按丰田标准算又很差，所以这是通用那些平庸工厂中最糟糕的一家。
Again, that's Jeffrey Liker, who's interviewed workers and management at Fremont for his research.
再说一次，这是Jeffrey Liker，他为研究采访了弗里蒙特的工人和管理层。
One of the expressions was, you can buy anything you want in the GM plant in Fremont. If you want sex, if you want drugs, if you want alcohol, it's there. During breaks, during lunch time, if you want to gamble illegally-- any illegal activity was available for the asking within that plant.
当时流行的一句话是，在弗里蒙特的通用工厂，你想买什么就能买到什么。如果你想要性、毒品或酒精，应有尽有。休息时间、午餐时间，如果你想非法赌博——任何非法活动在厂里只要开口就能办到。
Sounds like prison.
听起来像监狱。
Actually the analogy to prison is a good analogy. Because the workers were stuck there, because they could not find anything close to that level of job, and pay, and benefits, at their level of education and skill. So they were trapped there. And they also felt like, we have a job for life, and the union will always protect us. So we're stuck here, and it's long term, and then all these illegal things crop up so we can entertain ourselves while we're stuck here.
其实，用监狱来类比很贴切。因为工人们被困在那里，他们无法在他们所处的教育和技能水平下，找到任何接近该岗位工资和福利水平的工作。所以他们被困在了那里。他们也觉得，我们要么终身有保障，工会会一直保护我们。所以我们被困在这里，是长期的，然后所有这些非法勾当就会冒出来，这样我们在被困住时就能找点乐子。
A lot of booze on the line. I mean, it was just amazing-- and as long as you did your job, they really didn't care.
流水线上有很多酒。我是说，这太惊人了——只要你做了工作，他们其实根本不在乎。
What kind of booze, what were people drinking?
什么酒，大家喝什么？
Whiskey, gin.
威士忌、金酒。
That's Rick Madrid. He began working at the plant in 1955. He mounted tires on Chevy trucks.
那是Rick Madrid。他于1955年开始在工厂工作。他负责给雪佛兰卡车安装轮胎。
When I was mounting tires, we'd drink. You know, I'd bring a thermos of screwdrivers with me. But I never was into drugs.
当我在安装轮胎时，我们会喝酒。你知道，我随身带着一保温杯螺丝刀酒（伏特加兑橙汁）。但我从不碰毒品。
Sex?
性呢？
Love it.
喜欢。
Did you ever have sex at the plant?
你曾在厂里发生过性行为吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Frequently?
频繁吗？
I wasn't that fortunate.
我没那么幸运。
There was a guy in there, he would be selling the pot.
厂里有个家伙，他会卖大麻。
Peter Ross repaired machinery on the assembly line at GM.
Peter Ross在通用工厂负责维修组装线设备。
I'd be walking through the plant with my tools and my radio. You see a big cloud of smoke, you don't want to inhale it, you'd get a contact high.
我带着工具和收音机走在厂里。如果你看到一大团烟雾，你不想吸入它，你会产生接触性快感。
If you're wondering how people kept their jobs, well, back then the UAW was still quite powerful. Under the union contract, it was almost impossible to fire anybody, and if management ticked off the union, workers could just shut the plant down in minutes.
如果你好奇人们是怎么保住工作的，嗯，那时UAW依然非常有势力。根据工会合同，开除任何人几乎是不可能的，而且如果管理层激怒了工会，工人们几分钟内就能让工厂停产。
With that sort of leverage, absenteeism became absurd. On a normal day, one out of five workers just didn't show up. It was even worse on Mondays. Billy Haggerty worked in hood and fender assembly. He says so few workers showed up some mornings, management couldn't start the line.
有了这种筹码，缺勤现象变得荒谬起来。在平常的日子里，五分之一的工人根本不来上班。周一的情况甚至更糟。Billy Haggerty在引擎盖和挡泥板装配线上工作。他说有些早上来上班的人太少，管理层根本没法开动生产线。
They brought a lot of people off the street to fill in when they didn't have enough people.
他们从街上找很多人来填补空缺，因为人手不够。
Who would they find?
他们去哪找人？
Right across the street to the bar and grab people out of there and bring them in.
直接去街对面的酒吧把人拉过来。
Workers filed grievances-- formal complaints against management-- over all kinds of things. Someone who isn't your boss asks you to clean something up? Hit him with a grievance. A manager steps in to do a job that isn't his? Grievance. The strategy was simple. Pile up grievances real or imagined by the thousands, then use them to squeeze money or concessions out of management.
工人们针对各种事情提交申诉——即针对管理层的正式投诉。不是你上司的人让你打扫卫生？提申诉。经理插手做他不该做的工作？申诉。策略很简单：用成千上万个真实的或想象的申诉堆积起来，然后用它们向管理层索要金钱或让步。
And Fremont workers struck back at their bosses in other ways. They'd intentionally screw up the vehicles. Put coke bottles or loose bolts inside the door panels so they'd rattle and annoy the customer. They'd scratch cars. Richard Aguilar inspected vehicles at the plant. He saw one guy do something even worse.
弗里蒙特的工人们还以其他方式回击老板。他们会故意搞砸车辆，把可乐瓶或松动的螺栓放进门板里，让车子产生噪音并惹恼客户。他们还会划伤车身。Richard Aguilar是厂里的车辆检验员。他看到一个人做过更糟的事。
He left some loose bolts on the front suspension. That was dangerous. I went and told the system manager right away. They went out there and they checked, and there was like 400 cars he had done that to. He was mad because they had suspended him for drinking.
他在前悬架上留下了一些松动的螺栓。这很危险。我立刻去告诉了系统经理。他们过去检查了，发现他做了手脚的车有400辆之多。他生气是因为他们曾因他喝酒而停他的职。
By 1982, GM had had enough and put the Fremont factory out of its misery. The company laid off thousands of workers and closed the plant. The next year, when GM and Toyota began planning to reopen the plant for the joint venture, there was one thing neither company wanted to do-- hire the same union leaders who'd battled management and overseen GM's worst workforce. Then the UAW's Bruce Lee sat down with chairman Eiji Toyoda.
到1982年，通用忍无可忍，结束了弗里蒙特工厂的苦日子。公司解雇了数千名工人并关闭了工厂。第二年，当通用和丰田开始计划重新开放该工厂进行合资时，有一件事是两家公司都不想做的——雇用那些曾经对抗管理层并监管了通用最糟糕劳动力队伍的工会领导人。后来，UAW的Bruce Lee与丰田英二董事长坐到了一起。
And one of the first things I said is, "I've got to hire the first 50 people."
我说的第一件事就是：“我必须先雇佣前50个人。”
So who did you hire?
那你雇佣了谁？
The same leadership that was in the union before.
就是工会之前的同一批领导层。
Why? I thought you would try to get rid of them.
为什么？我以为你会试图摆脱他们。
No, no, because I believed that it was the system that made it bad, not the people.
不，不，因为我相信是系统导致了这一切变坏，而不是人。
GM was against it, but incredibly, Toyota agreed. Toyota execs believed their system would turn bad workers into good ones. Then Lee had to sell the plan to the rank and file. He held a meeting and told union members that Fremont would now be a Japanese style plant. Old seniority rules wouldn't apply, life at the plant would be totally different. The workers hated all this.
通用汽车是反对的，但令人难以置信的是，丰田同意了。丰田高管相信他们的系统会将坏员工变成好员工。然后Lee必须向普通员工推销这个计划。他召开了一次会议，告诉工会成员，弗里蒙特现在将变成一家日本风格的工厂。旧的资历规则将不再适用，厂里的生活将彻底改变。工人们对此非常反感。
They didn't want anything changed. They wanted the plant to open exactly how it was when General Motors had it.
他们什么都不想改变。他们想让工厂开张时和通用接手时一模一样。
Bad cars and all?
包括生产糟糕的汽车？
That's what they wanted.
他们要的就是这个。
They even hung Lee in effigy. But Lee had something very powerful on his side-- most of the workers desperately needed jobs, and Lee had them. When NUMMI opened, over 85% of the workforce were old hands from GM Fremont. But to prepare them for that moment, in the spring of 1984, Toyota started flying them to Japan in groups of 30 to begin learning the Toyota system for making cars.
他们甚至还搞了个草人挂起来诅咒Lee。但Lee身边有一股强大的力量——大多数工人都急需工作，而工作在Lee手里。NUMMI开业时，超过85%的劳动力都是通用弗里蒙特的老员工。但在1984年春天，为了让他们准备好迎接那一刻，丰田开始将他们分批送往日本，每批30人，开始学习丰田的汽车生产系统。
Well, when the NUMMI workers first came to Japan, me, and certainly my Japanese bosses, had heard all these horrible things about the American worker, about the American union.
嗯，当NUMMI工人第一次来到日本时，我和我的日本老板当然都听说过关于美国工人、关于美国工会的所有可怕传闻。
As the one American working in Toyota City, John Shook helped design this training.
作为在丰田市工作的唯一一个美国人，John Shook参与了这次培训的设计。
We had certainly heard all these stories about the workforce there at the Fremont plant. And it was our job to show them a new, very different way of working. What would they do? How would they respond to this? How would they react? And no one knew. I didn't know. So everyone was very, very nervous.
我们确实听说过很多关于弗里蒙特工厂劳动力的传闻。我们的任务是向他们展示一种全新的、截然不同的工作方式。他们会怎么做？他们会有什么反应？没人知道。我也不知道。所以大家都非常、非常紧张。
I was kind of apprehensive about what I was going to see when I arrived in Japan.
当我抵达日本时，我对即将看到的一切感到有些不安。
On one of those planes was Earl Ferguson. He'd been working for GM since 1964.
那些飞机上就有Earl Ferguson。他自1964年起就在通用工作。
What were you apprehensive about?
你对什么感到不安？
Whether they were going to accept us or not, you know. How they're going to react when the Americans landed in Tokyo. Everything was so new to us, you know, this is just a totally new experience.
他们会不会接纳我们，你知道。当美国人在东京落地时，他们会作何反应。一切对我们来说都太新鲜了，这完全是一次全新的体验。
So I will never forget--
所以我永远不会忘记——
Again, John Shook.
还是John Shook。
Taking a bus, a large bus, with my small group of Japanese colleagues to pick up the first group of trainees arriving from Fremont. Television cameras were there because this was big news in Japan at the time.
坐上一辆大巴，载着我的一小群日本同事去接第一批从弗里蒙特抵达的学员。电视台摄像机都在那儿，因为这在当时的日本是个大新闻。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语发言]
As they got off the plane, we had signs welcoming them.
当他们下飞机时，我们举着欢迎他们的标语。
The news media was everywhere. We were signing autographs and taking pictures with all the young kids. Totally new experience.
新闻媒体到处都是。我们在签名、和所有的年轻孩子们拍照。完全是全新的体验。
Most of them had never been out of the United States before. None of them, certainly, had ever been to Japan.
他们中大多数人以前从未离开过美国。他们中当然没有人去过日本。
My name is Les Myers. I've worked at General Motors for 25 years. My hobbies are fishing and bowling.
我叫Les Myers。我在通用汽车工作了25年。我的爱好是钓鱼和保龄球。
My name is [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]. My hobby's softball.
我叫[模糊短语]。我的爱好是垒球。
The narrator in this Japanese public television program points out that the American worker is nine years older than his Toyota trainer. He also notes for his Japanese viewers that the Americans are so much larger than the Japanese they waste a second or two more each time they get in and out of the vehicles they're building, which makes them 10 to 15% less productive than their Asian counterparts.
日本公共电视节目的解说指出，美国工人的平均年龄比他的丰田培训师大九岁。他还向日本观众指出，美国人比日本人高大得多，所以他们每次上下车时会浪费一两秒钟，这使他们的生产效率比亚洲同行低10%到15%。
The key to the Toyota production system was a principle so basic it sounds like an empty management slogan-- teamwork. Back home in Fremont, GM supervisors ordered around large groups of workers. The Takaoka plant, people were divided into teams of just four or five-- switch jobs every few hours to relieve the monotony. And a team leader would step in to help whenever anything went wrong.
丰田生产系统的关键原则极其基础，听起来像是一个空洞的管理口号——团队合作。回到弗里蒙特的老家，通用主管会指挥一大群工人。在丰田高冈工厂，人们被分成四五人的小组——每隔几个小时就轮换工作以缓解单调感。每当出现问题时，团队领导就会介入提供帮助。
Again, Professor Jeffrey Liker and Toyota's John Shook.
再次是Jeffrey Liker教授和丰田的John Shook。
And they spent about two weeks, and they worked in a Toyota plant.
他们待了大约两周，在丰田工厂工作。
Hooked up at the hip with a counterpart in the Corolla plant-- someone who did the exact same job you would be doing back in Fremont.
和卡罗拉工厂的一位对应员工“绑在一起”——那个人从事的工作和你回到弗里蒙特后要做的完全一样。
And they start to do the job, and they were pretty proud because they were building cars back in the United States, and they wanted to show they could do it within the time allotted, and they would usually get behind. And they would struggle, and they would try to catch up, and at some point, somebody would come over and say, do you want me to help? And that was a revelation, because nobody in the GM plant would ever ask to help. They would come yell at you because you got behind.
他们开始做这份工作，他们相当自豪，因为他们在回美国后要造车，他们想证明自己能在规定的时间内完成。通常他们会落后。他们会挣扎，会试图赶上，就在某个时候，有人会走过来问：“需要我帮忙吗？”那是一种启示，因为在通用工厂，从没人会主动提出帮忙。他们只会因为你落后而对你大吼大叫。
Really, we wanted to give them a chance to see and experience a different way of doing things. We wanted them to see the culture there, the way people work together to solve problems.
我们真的想给他们一个机会去观察和体验不同的做事方式。我们想让他们看到那里的文化，人们如何合作解决问题。
Then the biggest surprise was, when they had those problems, afterwards, somebody would come up to them and say, what are your ideas for improvement so we don't have that problem again?
然后最大的惊喜是，当他们遇到问题时，之后会有人走过来问他们：“你对改进有什么想法，这样我们就不会再遇到那个问题了？”
So they'd make suggestions for a different kind of tool that would be better for the job, or a different place for bolts and parts to sit that would be easier to reach.
所以他们会提出建议，比如改进某种工具让工作更好做，或者改变螺栓和零件存放的位置，以便更容易拿取。
They couldn't believe that responsiveness. I can't remember anytime in my working life where anybody asked for my ideas to solve the problem. And they literally want to know, and when I tell them, they listen, and then suddenly, they disappear and somebody comes back with the tool that I just described-- it's built-- and they say, "Try this."
他们简直不敢相信这种响应速度。我记不得在我职业生涯中有谁征求过我解决问题的想法。他们真的是想知道，当我告诉他们时，他们会听，然后突然间，他们消失了，有人回来拿着我刚才描述的工具——那是现做的——他们说：“试试这个。”
Under the Toyota system, when a worker makes a suggestion that saves money, he gets a bonus of a few hundred dollars or so. Everyone's expected to be looking for ways to improve the production process, all the time. This is the Japanese concept of kaizen, or continuous improvement.
在丰田系统下，当工人提出一个节省成本的建议时，他会获得几百美元左右的奖金。每个人都被期待时刻寻找改进生产过程的方法。这就是日本的“改善”（kaizen）理念，即持续改进。
And if you look around a Toyota plant, you can see the result of all those improvements. You see mats for workers to stand on, special cushions they throw into the car frames when they have to kneel inside, hanging shelves that travel along with the car and the worker, carrying parts and bolts they need within easy reach. Similarly, workers tasks have been streamlined to the fewest possible steps, each step timed down to the second.
如果你环顾丰田工厂，你可以看到所有这些改进的结果。你会看到工人站立用的垫子，当他们不得不跪着作业时扔进车架里的特制靠垫，随车和工人一起移动的悬挂式货架，载着他们所需的零件和螺栓，触手可及。同样，工人的任务被简化为尽可能少的步骤，每一步都精确到秒。
Two seconds to pick up a bolt and put it on. Two seconds to take a gun and tighten it down.
两秒钟捡起螺栓放好。两秒钟拿起枪把螺栓拧紧。
Billy Haggerty learned the Japanese system two decades into his tenure at GM Fremont.
Billy Haggerty在通用弗里蒙特工作了20年后才学到这个日本系统。
Everything was timed out, such and such takes such and such long to do-- that's the way you did it. At General Motors, you could be running in circles for whatever you were doing, and that's the way it is. You lose time. A car a minute don't seem like it's moving that fast, but when you don't get it, you're in the hole. There's nobody to pull you out at General Motors, so you're going to let something go.
一切都计时完毕，某某东西需要多久完成——这就是你做事的方式。在通用汽车，你可能因为做任何事都在兜圈子，事情就是这样。你浪费了时间。一分钟一辆车看起来移动得没那么快，但当你跟不上时，你就惨了。在通用汽车没人在你落后时拉你一把，所以你只能让问题就这样过去。
All those mistakes added up at a GM plant, and the results were littered around the lots outside-- hundreds of misassembled cars. Cars that came off the line missing parts. Cars that needed to be fixed before they could be shipped out to the dealers. In a Toyota plant, there was nothing like this. Why did a GM plant produce so many screwed up cars? One cardinal rule that everybody in the company knew.
在通用工厂，所有这些错误累积起来，结果就是厂房外的地块上堆满了成百上千辆组装错误的汽车。生产线上下来的车缺少零件。在运往经销商之前必须先进行修理。在丰田工厂，根本没有这样的事。为什么通用工厂生产了这么多烂车？每个人都知道的一条准则。
The line could never stop. Never stop the line.
生产线绝对不能停。永远别停生产线。
Again, Billy Haggerty, Jeffrey Liker, Rick Madrid, and Bruce Lee.
再次是Billy Haggerty、Jeffrey Liker、Rick Madrid和Bruce Lee。
Someone had a heart attack, kick him out the way, keep that line running.
有人心脏病发作了，把他踢到一边，让流水线继续运行。
It was a basic sin. You're violating the 10 commandments.
这是一种基本的罪恶。你违反了十诫。
You just don't see the line stop. I saw a guy fall in the pit and they didn't stop the line.
你根本看不到生产线停下来。我亲眼看到一个人掉进坑里，他们都没停下生产线。
You saw a problem, you stop that line, you were fired.
你看到了问题，你停止了生产线，你就被开除了。
A long time GM manager named Ernie Schaefer explained why.
一位叫Ernie Schaefer的通用老经理解释了原因。
Because the theory was, they'll stop it all the time. They don't want to work, you know, they want to sit and play cards or whatever. You know, that was a free break for them, if the line stops, so you wouldn't give them the ability to stop the line.
因为理论是：他们会一直停下来。你知道，他们不想干活，他们想坐着打牌或者干别的。你知道，如果生产线停了，对他们来说就是免费的休息时间，所以你不能给他们停掉生产线的能力。
John Shook, the American who helped Toyota design its training program, says this all goes back to the first assembly line created by Henry Ford.
帮助丰田设计培训项目的美国人John Shook说，这一切都要追溯到亨利·福特创造的第一条流水线。
What Henry Ford had basically designed was a system that-- he wanted the people on the floor to simply get the volume out, get the product out the door, and someone later will worry about the quality. If we have to repair it, we'll repair it.
亨利·福特设计的基本上是一个系统——他希望流水线上的人仅仅为了产量，把产品弄出去，至于质量以后会有人担心。如果必须修理，那我们就修理。
So one of the most fundamental things that Toyota did was take that and turn it on its head. So that now we tell the plant floor, don't you worry about the production volume, you worry about quality. The last thing we want is to have a lot of defects flowing down the line that we have to repair later.
所以丰田做的最根本的事情之一就是把这一点完全颠倒过来。现在我们告诉生产线：别担心产量，担心质量。我们最不希望看到的就是流水线上流出大量必须在之后进行返工的残次品。
Toyota's philosophy was quality, not quantity.
丰田的哲学是质量优先，而非产量优先。
In his old GM job, Billy Haggerty put on hoods and fenders, and saw lots of mistakes go right down the line. So we had Monte Carlos with Regal front ends, and vice versa, and they would just stick it on, run it out to the yard, and then change.
在以前通用汽车的工作中，Billy Haggerty负责安装引擎盖和挡泥板，看到很多错误就这样一路流下来。我们有装了Regal车头的Monte Carlo，反之亦然，他们就把零件装上去，开到堆场，然后再换。
What did they look like, the cars?
那些车看起来像什么？
Half Regals and half-- so those things would go out the door into the yard and be fixed out there. I did a lot of overtime in the yard changing things back.
一半像Regal一半像别的——所以那些东西会开出去堆在场里等着修理。我在堆场加了很多班来把它们换回来。
Workers told me they saw cars with engines put in backwards, cars without steering wheels or brakes. Some were so messed up they wouldn't start, and had to be towed off the line. Fixing them piled on more costs, and sometimes, taking them apart and putting them back together, workers damaged them even more.
工人们告诉我，他们看到过引擎装反的车，没方向盘或没刹车的车。有些车坏得太严重了以至于无法启动，不得不被拖下流水线。修理它们增加了更多成本，而且有时在拆卸和重新装配过程中，工人们损坏得更严重。
On the floor of the NUMMI plant in Fremont, Earl Ferguson showed me Toyota's solution to all this. It's a thin nylon rope that hangs on hooks along the assembly line, which became a symbol of everything that was different about the Japanese way of making cars-- the andon cord.
在弗里蒙特NUMMI工厂的车间里，Earl Ferguson向我展示了丰田解决所有这些问题的方案。那是一根沿着装配线悬挂的细尼龙绳，它成了日本造车方式不同于美国方式的象征——“安灯绳”（andon cord）。
These cords hanging down, that's the andon cord. It will stop the line. If he pulls the andon cord, then this light's going to come on, right here. Then it'll show up on the screen that this location is down.
这些垂下来的绳子，就是安灯绳。它会停止生产线。如果他拉下安灯绳，这盏灯就会亮起来，就在这里。然后屏幕上会显示这个位置停工了。
It also plays a surprisingly cheerful little song. Workers in each area can pick the tune. You hear it all the time in a Toyota plant. The first pull doesn't stop the line, it summons team leaders to the location. They try to correct the problem, and usually, they can do it quickly without stopping production. But if they fail, the line stops.
它还会播放一首出人意料的欢快小曲。每个区域的工人可以选择曲调。你在丰田工厂总是能听到它。第一次拉动不会停止生产线，它会呼叫团队领导来到现场。他们尝试纠正问题，通常他们可以很快解决而不停止生产。但如果他们失败了，生产线就会停。
Then they'll correct the problem, then you can pull the andon cord again, and the line will start.
然后他们纠正问题，然后你再拉动安灯绳，生产线就会启动。
Now when was the first time you ever pulled an andon cord?
那么你第一次拉动安灯绳是什么时候？
1984.
1984年。
Where did you do it?
你在哪里做的？
In Japan.
在日本。
Were you at all nervous, because you'd been taught for so many years never to stop the line?
你当时紧张吗，因为你多年来一直被教导绝不能停止生产线？
Yeah. And it was really exciting. What got me was the fact that they had a cross bolt, and they stopped the line to repair it. Ream the hole, put the bolt back in, instead of sending it on and putting all the other junk on top of it, so you have to take it off and repair it. And whoever puts it back isn't skilled in putting trim back, so they're going to mess that up.
是的。而且非常激动。打动我的是，他们发现了一个错位螺栓，他们停下生产线去修理。扩孔，把螺栓放回去，而不是把它放行，在上面堆满所有其他杂乱的零部件，以至于你不得不拆掉它们去修理。而且负责装回的人并不擅长装回内饰，所以他们会把事情搞砸。
That impressed me. Said, gee, that makes sense, fix it now so you don't have to go through all this stuff. That's when it dawned on me that we can do it-- one bolt. One bolt changed my attitude.
那让我印象深刻。我想，天哪，这说得通，现在就修好它，这样你就不用经历所有这些烂事了。就在那时，我意识到我们能做到——一个螺栓。一个螺栓改变了我的态度。
I think that there was a combination of feelings. One feeling was, wow, this is different.
我认为那是一种混合的感觉。一种感觉是：哇，这太不同了。
Again, that's industrial engineering professor Jeffrey Liker.
再次是工业工程教授Jeffrey Liker。
Another feeling was of embarrassment. We've been in this industry for how many years-- my whole adult life-- we're Americans, we're supposed to be the best, most important country in the world, and we can't build a quality car. And these Japanese are doing it. And there was a sense of hurt pride.
另一种感觉是尴尬。我们在这个行业干了多少年——我的整个成年生活——我们是美国人，我们本该是世界上最棒、最重要的国家，但我们造不出高质量的汽车。而这些日本人却做到了。这是一种受伤的自尊心。
Well, it was kind of, you become a little bit ashamed, because why couldn't we do that?
嗯，这有点像是一种……你会感到一点羞愧，因为为什么我们做不到？
Again, Earl Ferguson.
再次是Earl Ferguson。
You know, I think most of it was pride after that. We wanted to be able to compete with what I saw in Japan. I said, I know we can do what they can do.
你知道，我认为那之后大部分是骄傲。我们想证明我们能与我在日本所见的一切竞争。我说，我知道我们能做到他们能做到的事。
Only two weeks later when that first group left to go back to Fremont--
仅仅两周后，当第一批员工离开准备回到弗里蒙特时——
Toyota trainer, John Shook.
丰田培训师，John Shook。
We had a party, of course, a sushi party-- and this was years ago, before sushi was as it is now. It was still a rare thing, of course. And people were crying on both sides. You had union workers-- grizzled old folks that had worked on the plant floor for 30 years, and they were hugging their Japanese counterparts, just absolutely in tears.
我们举行了一场聚会，当然，是一场寿司聚会——那是几年前的事，在寿司还没像现在这么普及的时候。那时这仍然是一件罕见的事。人们双方都在哭泣。工会工人们——那些已经在流水线上工作了30年的老手们，正在拥抱他们的日本同行，眼泪夺眶而出。
There's actually footage of this, though we don't know if it's the first group of Americans. US workers are in kimonos with the Toyota name on them. And they hand their neckties to the Japanese and hug. One man is crying.
实际上有这段录像，尽管我们不知道这是否是第一批美国人。美国工人们穿着印有丰田名字的和服。他们把领带递给日本人并拥抱。一个人正在哭泣。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语发言]
One of the Americans says, in Japanese, "Thanks to you all, we now feel confident for our success." John Shook.
其中一个美国人用日语说：“多亏了大家，我们现在对成功充满信心。”John Shook。
And it might sound flowery to say 25 years later, but they had had such a powerful emotional experience of learning a new way of working, a way that people could actually work together collaboratively-- as a team. We knew it wasn't going to be easy-- there were a lot of hurdles to overcome-- but there was no question in anyone's mind that this was going to work.
25年后说出来可能听起来有些华丽，但他们经历了一次如此强大的情感体验——学习一种新的工作方式，一种人们可以真正协作的工作方式——作为一个团队。我们知道这不会容易——有很多障碍需要克服——但在任何人心中，这都会成功，这一点毋庸置疑。
But if it was going to work, it would mean a radically different relationship between workers and management. One where the managers trusted the workers to let them pull the andon cord and stop the line. One where the workers trusted their bosses enough to ask for help when there were problems.
但如果它要成功，就意味着工人和管理层之间将建立一种彻底不同的关系。一种管理层信任工人、允许他们拉动安灯绳并停止生产线的关系。一种工人足够信任老板，在遇到问题时愿意求助的关系。
With teamwork, we can do it all. [? Now let's hold up your hands, and together-- with teamwork, we can do it all.
通过团队合作，我们能做到一切。[？现在让我们举起双手，一起——通过团队合作，我们能做到一切。
December, 1984, the first car rolled off the assembly line in Fremont, a yellow Chevy Nova. UAW rep Joel Smith was one of the speakers.
1984年12月，第一辆车在弗里蒙特装配线下线，一辆黄色雪佛兰Nova。UAW代表Joel Smith是发言人之一。
Mr. Toyoda, staff, and fellow UAW members, today is a historic one-- the first car. But we're also on the threshold of a new adventure and relationship between labor and management. For too long, the American worker has been maligned, criticized, called bad names, for building lousy products. Poor quality American worker.
丰田先生、员工们，以及UAW的工友们，今天是历史性的一天——第一辆车下线。但我们也正处于劳资关系新冒险的门槛上。长期以来，美国工人一直受到诽谤、批评，被冠以恶名，仅仅因为生产了质量低劣的产品。劣质的美国工人。
At New United Motor, we will build a quality car, and we will only build a quality car. And Mr. Toyoda, if you would please deliver this challenge to our friends in Japan, we intend to build the best quality car in the world. Thank you.
在“新联合汽车制造公司”，我们将制造高质量的汽车，而且我们只会制造高质量的汽车。丰田先生，如果您能将这一挑战传达给我们在日本的朋友，我们打算制造世界上最高质量的汽车。谢谢。
They hit the ground running. It didn't take a year, two years, to get quality in that product.
他们一开局就非常顺利。产品达到高质量并没有花上一年、两年。
Again, the UAW's Bruce Lee.
再次是UAW的Bruce Lee。
Oh, I was so proud of them, you can't even believe. The fact that they did it didn't surprise me that much, but how quickly they did it did. It was amazing. Here was these same people, who before-- I mean, hell, they'd go out of their way to make life miserable for General Motors particularly. And, you know, they were old, they were fat. Because that was not a young workforce that we brought in there.
哦，我为他们感到骄傲，你简直无法相信。事实上他们做到了并没有让我那么惊讶，但他们做到得那么快却让我震惊。太惊人了。这就是同一批人，他们以前——天哪，他们甚至会特意把通用汽车的日子过得惨不忍睹。而且你知道，他们老了，胖了。因为我们带进那里的并不是年轻的劳动力。
The numbers coming out of the NUMMI plant were astonishing. Again, here's Jeffrey Liker.
NUMMI工厂产生的数据令人惊叹。再次请出Jeffrey Liker。
The best measure they use is how many defects are there per 100 vehicles. And it was one of the best in America, and it was for the same for the Toyota cars that were made in California as the Corollas that were coming from Japan-- right from the beginning.
他们使用的最好衡量指标是每100辆车中有多少缺陷。它在美国名列前茅，在加州制造的丰田汽车和从日本运来的卡罗拉汽车水平一样——从一开始就是如此。
Maryann Keller, a long time car analyst, devotes a chapter to NUMMI in her book about the rise and fall of GM, Rude Awakening. After just three months, she says, the cars coming off the line were getting near perfect quality ratings. And just as important for GM were the cost savings. One study suggested, remarkably, it would probably take 50% more workers under the old system to build the same car.
长期的汽车分析师Maryann Keller在她的著作《觉醒》（Rude Awakening）中专门用一章来讲述NUMMI对通用汽车兴衰的影响。她说，仅仅三个月后，下线的汽车就达到了近乎完美的质量评级。对通用同样重要的是成本节约。一项研究令人震惊地指出，按照旧系统，可能需要多出50%的工人来制造同一辆车。
Grievances and absenteeism plummeted, and lots of workers preferred the NUMMI teamwork system to the old combative one at GM. Several told us they enjoyed coming to work for the first time.
申诉和缺勤大幅下降，许多工人更喜欢NUMMI的团队协作系统，而不是通用以前那种对抗性的系统。几个人告诉我们，他们第一次喜欢来上班了。
I didn't want to tell people I worked at the Chevy truck plant, because a lot of people had a lot of problems with them.
我不想告诉别人我在雪佛兰卡车工厂工作，因为很多人对它们有很多意见。
That's Rick Madrid, who spent 17 years at the old Fremont plant building Chevy trucks. He was ashamed of that vehicle. At NUMMI, making the Nova, he felt differently.
那是Rick Madrid，他在旧弗里蒙特工厂制造雪佛兰卡车呆了17年。他为那种产品感到羞耻。在NUMMI生产Nova时，他的感觉不同了。
Oh I had a stack of these postcards, and I would just drive around, if I see a Nova parked, I would put one of these under the windshield wiper. Of course, it had my name, my address on it, and your opinion of the Nova. And just basically, they dropped me a line. And a lot of people did this.
哦，我有一叠这样的明信片，我会到处开车，如果我看到一辆Nova停在那里，我会把其中一张放在挡风玻璃雨刮器下。当然，上面有我的名字、地址，以及你对Nova的意见。基本上就是，请给我写封信。很多人都这样做。
And what did they say?
他们说了什么？
Some said they really liked it, a quality car, a good car.
有些人说他们真的很喜欢它，高质量的汽车，好车。
Another worker told me he'd go to the Chevy dealership to stare at the Novas. He didn't tell anyone he built them, or that he worked at NUMMI. He just liked seeing what the cars looked like, sitting there on the lot.
另一个工人告诉我，他会去雪佛兰经销商那里盯着Nova看。他没有告诉任何人是他造的，或者他在NUMMI工作。他只是喜欢看那些车在停车场里的样子。
That's NPR's Frank Langfitt. Coming up, so there's this great way of making cars, GM is using it  in California. Not only are the cars more reliable, they're cheaper to make. Seems like a no-brainer for GM-- start putting this way of producing cars into their other factories everywhere, and declare victory. Why they didn't do that, why what happened at NUMMI stayed at NUMMI for so long, that's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
这是NPR的Frank Langfitt。接下来，有一种造车的好方法，通用正在加州使用它。不仅汽车更可靠，而且制造成本更低。对通用来说这似乎是个显而易见的选择——开始把这种生产方式引入到他们其他地方的工厂，宣布胜利。为什么他们没有那样做，为什么NUMMI发生的事情在NUMMI停留了那么久，那将在来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台的节目继续时揭晓。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. If you're just tuning in, we're in the middle of a story about a car plant in Fremont, California, called NUMMI. We now turn to the question, why was it so hard for GM to replicate NUMMI elsewhere in the company. In the first half of our story, we heard a lot from workers who are on the factory floor. In this half of the story, the action moves to their bosses-- the supervisors at GM, who had a chance to turn the company around with what they learned at NUMMI. Again, here's NPR's Frank Langfitt.
这是《This American Life》，我是Ira Glass。如果你刚调过来，我们正在讲述一个加州弗里蒙特汽车工厂NUMMI的故事。我们现在转入那个问题：为什么通用很难在公司其他地方复制NUMMI。在我们故事的前半部分，我们听到了很多来自车间工人的声音。在这半部分，动作转移到了他们的老板——通用的主管们身上，他们有机会通过在NUMMI学到的东西来扭转公司。再次请出NPR的Frank Langfitt。
GM had gotten the first thing it wanted out of NUMMI-- a high quality small car. Now the question was, how could it spread the lessons of NUMMI throughout the rest of the company? To do that, it set up a special liaison office. Managers were flown in for tours, to work the assembly line for a few days, to learn the team concept.
通用已经从NUMMI那里得到了它想要的第一样东西——高质量小型车。现在的问题是，它该如何将NUMMI的教训传播到公司其他地方？为了做到这一点，它设立了一个特别联络办公室。经理们被飞往这里参观，在装配线上工作几天，学习团队概念。
And from the beginning, GM executives sent 16 of their rising stars to help start NUMMI, with the idea that later they'd come home and change the company. Two Wall Street Journal reporters later dubbed them the NUMMI commandos. One of the 16 was Mark Hogan. He says the top brass understood NUMMI's game changing potential-- that a Toyota style plant squeezed many more cars out of far fewer workers.
从一开始，通用高管就派出了16位冉冉升起的明星来帮助启动NUMMI，想法是以后他们会回家并改变公司。《华尔街日报》的两位记者后来称他们为“NUMMI突击队员”。这16人中有一位是Mark Hogan。他说高层领导理解NUMMI改变游戏规则的潜力——即丰田式的工厂能用少得多的工人榨出更多的汽车。
If General Motors was able to take its many manufacturing facilities and implement that production system, each of those little changes adds up to billions to General Motors in the bottom line.
如果通用汽车能够利用其众多制造设施并实施该生产系统，每一个小的改变加起来将为通用的盈亏底线带来数十亿美元。
We were ready, we were fired, and we had the mental condition that says, we're going to do this, we're going to change the world.
我们准备好了，我们很有干劲，我们有一种心态，说我们要做到这一点，我们要改变世界。
That's Steve Bera, another commando. He says once NUMMI was up and running, he and the other 15 waited to be deployed elsewhere for the next phase of their mission. But the company didn't seem to know what to do with them.
这是Steve Bera，另一位突击队员。他说一旦NUMMI运转起来，他和另外15人就等待着被部署到其他地方执行任务的下一阶段。但公司似乎不知道怎么处理他们。
Instead of coming back to the 16 of us and saying, there's some secret sauce here, what is it? How can we use this to our advantage? No one ever asked us that question.
他们没有回到我们16个人身边说，这里有一些秘方，是什么呢？我们如何利用它来发挥我们的优势？没有人问过我们那个问题。
Why didn't they do that?
为什么他们没有那样做？
It was never part of a master plan. And if there was a master plan, none of us ever saw it.
这从来不是总体规划的一部分。即使有总体规划，我们中也从未有人见过。
Frustrated, Steve Bera quit after just two years at NUMMI. With no master plan from Detroit, the first real attempt to do NUMMI again came from a factory manager 400 miles south of Fremont, at a plant in Van Nuys. The factory was facing a possible shut down.
Steve Bera感到沮丧，在NUMMI待了仅仅两年就辞职了。由于底特律没有总体规划，第二次真正尝试复制NUMMI的是弗里蒙特以南400英里的范奈斯（Van Nuys）一家工厂的厂长。该工厂面临可能关闭的危机。
Its manager, a guy named Ernie Schaefer, had visited NUMMI, and he thought maybe he could save his plant if he adopted the Japanese system. But he didn't have all the advantages Fremont had-- this time, Toyota wasn't a partner in the experiment. GM had to transform Van Nuys on its own. Ernie Schaefer knew it was going to be tough.
它的经理Ernie Schaefer参观过NUMMI，他想如果能采用日本系统，也许能挽救他的工厂。但他没有弗里蒙特那样的所有优势——这一次，丰田不是实验的合作伙伴。通用必须独自改造范奈斯。Ernie Schaefer知道这将是一场硬仗。
The thing that I think kept us moving forward is we had no alternative. I mean, it was pretty well known that if we didn't successfully implement this philosophy in Van Nuys, we weren't going to be around.
我想让我们继续前进的原因是别无选择。我的意思是，大家都清楚，如果我们不能在范奈斯成功实施这一哲学，我们就玩完了。
Van Nuys made Firebirds and Camaros, and its reputation wasn't much better than GM Fremont's had been. Defective cars coming off the line, battles with the union, sabotage. So Ernie Schaefer enlisted the same UAW leader who got the union on board at NUMMI, Bruce Lee, to help him win over the Van Nuys workforce.
范奈斯生产火鸟和科迈罗，其声誉并不比通用弗里蒙特好多少。下线的残次品、与工会的战斗、破坏行为。所以Ernie Schaefer请求同一位让NUMMI工会加入该计划的UAW领袖Bruce Lee，帮助他说服范奈斯的劳动力。
They shut down the plant for two weeks to train everyone in team concept and quality control. For this workforce, there were no trips to Japan, no tearful sushi parties, and from the start, workers were skeptical.
他们关闭工厂两周，对所有人进行团队概念和质量控制培训。对于这批劳动力，没有去日本的旅行，没有充满泪水的寿司聚会，而且从一开始，工人们就持怀疑态度。
The lack of receptiveness to change was so deep--
对变革的接受度如此之低——
Larry Spiegel was another NUMMI commando. He moved down to Van Nuys to help launch the Japanese system there.
Larry Spiegel是另一位NUMMI突击队员。他搬到范奈斯协助在那里启动日本系统。
There were too many people convinced that they didn't need to have to change.
有太多人确信他们不需要改变。
Hadn't General Motors threatened to close the plant?
通用汽车不是威胁要关闭工厂了吗？
They didn't believe it.
他们不相信。
Why?
为什么？
It's not logical. They just didn't.
这不合逻辑。他们就是不信。
This was one of the biggest differences between Fremont and Van Nuys. Van Nuys hadn't been shut down. Turns out, it's a lot easier to get workers to change if they've lost their jobs and then you offer them back. Without that, many union members just saw the Toyota system as a threat.
这是弗里蒙特和范奈斯之间最大的区别之一。范奈斯并没有被关闭过。事实证明，如果工人们失去了工作，然后你再把他们雇回来，让他们改变要容易得多。没有这一点，许多工会成员只是把丰田系统视为一种威胁。
And they had a point. Under the Japanese system, Van Nuys stood to lose a fourth of its workforce, because the more efficient a plant becomes, the fewer workers it needs. And just as bad, the team concept hurt their seniority rights. This had been a problem for union members back at NUMMI also.
他们说得有道理。在丰田系统下，范奈斯可能会失去四分之一的劳动力，因为工厂效率越高，需要的工人就越少。同样糟糕的是，团队概念损害了他们的资历权。这在NUMMI的工会成员身上也是个问题。
Seniority is what you work for. To me, that's what a union's about, seniority.
资历是你争取来的。对我来说，这就是工会的意义所在，资历。
Richard Aguilar worked at NUMMI, and to him, seniority was just another way of saying fairness. He waited 15 years to get enough seniority for the job he'd always wanted in the plant. Under the new system, management could just hire someone off the street for that job. The whole idea of seniority placing you into one great job for years was impossible under the team concept. Workers had to learn every job on their team and take turns doing those jobs.
Richard Aguilar曾在NUMMI工作，对他来说，资历只是公平的另一种说法。他等了15年才得到他一直想要的岗位。在新的系统下，管理层可以直接从街上雇一个人来做那份工作。在团队概念下，资历让你多年占据一个好岗位的整个想法是不可能的。工人们必须学习团队中的每一项工作，并轮流做这些工作。
And the team concept, it sounds good-- I mean, team player sounds good. But it pit worker against worker, it really does.
团队概念听起来不错——我的意思是，“团队球员”听起来不错。但它让工人和工人对立，真的。
This was the other thing Richard hated about the Japanese system. The whole point of a union, its most basic principle, was to protect you from management. But once people were working in teams, Richard says, union members started doing things for management that just seemed wrong.
这是Richard讨厌日本系统的另一件事。工会的整个意义，它最基本的原则，就是保护你免受管理层的侵害。但Richard说，一旦人们在团队中工作，工会成员就开始为管理层做一些似乎错误的事情。
People now snitched on each other. You know, they'd point fingers, oh, he's not doing his job right, you know, or she's not doing the job right. And they would even keep track of the stuff they'd missed. Because that's what the company puts in them, that the only way you can protect your job, you have to keep the team strong, so if there's a weak link, you've got to get rid of that weak link.
人们现在开始互相告密。你知道，他们会指指点点，“哦，他没把工作做好”，或者“她没把工作做好”。他们甚至会记录下他们错过的东西。因为这就是公司灌输给他们的，只有这样你才能保住工作，你必须保持团队强大，所以如果有薄弱环节，你就得除掉那个环节。
And I would go tell them, you can't do that. You can't build a case for management against another union member. It made me angry and disappointed that the union had gone so backwards that they forgot what a union meant-- taking care of each other.
我会去告诉他们，你们不能那样做。你们不能为管理层构陷另一个工会成员。这让我愤怒和失望，工会已经如此倒退，以至于忘记了工会的真正含义——互相关心。
At Van Nuys, it wasn't just union members who resisted the Japanese system. Managers didn't like it either. They had their own privileges to protect. Some opposed the idea of stopping the assembly line because their bonuses depended on the number of cars that rolled off that line-- never mind how many defects they had.
在范奈斯，不仅仅是工会成员抵制日本系统。经理们也不喜欢它。他们有自己的特权要维护。有些人反对停止生产线的想法，因为他们的奖金取决于下线的汽车数量——至于有多少缺陷他们不在乎。
And under the team concept, executives and workers all share the same cafeteria and parking lot. Managers at NUMMI didn't have a problem with that, but the managers at Van Nuys?
而且在团队概念下，高管和工人都共用同一个食堂和停车场。NUMMI的经理对此没问题，但范奈斯的经理呢？
They rioted.
他们暴动了。
The UAW's Bruce Lee remembers getting a phone call from plant supervisor Ernie Schaefer about his managers.
UAW的Bruce Lee记得接到过厂长Ernie Schaefer关于他的经理们的电话。
They'd basically told Ernie, you do that and we're out of here. We're going to quit en masse. Because Ernie called me, he said, "Bruce, I can't do it. I can't do it. I can't do those things." I said, "Just think about it, that's a nothing. So they have to walk 20 yards more." I said, "Isn't that foolish that some grown man would come up and tell you, I'm going to quit if I can't have this parking place right here."
他们基本上告诉Ernie，你如果那样做我们就走了。我们要集体辞职。因为Ernie打电话给我，他说：“Bruce，我做不到。我做不到。我做不到那些事。”我说：“想想看，那没什么大不了的。所以他们得多走20码路。”我说：“因为不能拥有那个停车位就要辞职，这难道不是很愚蠢吗？”
So people fought the new system from both sides. Managers gave Ernie grief, and a dissident faction sprang up in the local union, which elected a staunch opponent of the Japanese system as their chairman. And as if that all wasn't enough, Ernie Schaefer ran into another obstacle. Workers could only build cars as good as the parts they were given. At NUMMI, many of the parts came from Japan, and were really good. At Van Nuys, it was totally different.
所以人们从两方面对抗新系统。经理们让Ernie难受，工会内部也出现了一个异议派别，选出了一个日本系统的坚定反对者作为主席。而且仿佛这些还不够，Ernie Schaefer遇到了另一个障碍。工人们制造的汽车质量只能等同于他们拿到的零件质量。在NUMMI，许多零件来自日本，质量很好。但在范奈斯，完全不同。
That was perhaps one of our biggest failures, in that an isolated plant can't do this by itself.
这也许是我们最大的失败之一，一个孤立的工厂是无法独自做到这一点的。
The team concept stressed continuous improvement. If the team got a shipment of parts that didn't fit, they were supposed to alert their bosses, who would then go to suppliers and engineers to fix the problem. All the departments in the company worked together.
团队概念强调持续改进。如果团队收到了一批不匹配的零件，他们应该提醒老板，老板随后会去找供应商和工程师解决问题。公司所有部门共同协作。
But Ernie's suppliers had never operated in a system like that. If he asked for fixes, they blew him off. And if he called Detroit and asked them to redesign a part that wasn't working, they'd ask him why he was so special-- they didn't have to change it for any other plant, why should they change it for him?
但Ernie的供应商从未在那种系统中操作过。如果他要求维修，他们会不理他。如果他打电话给底特律要求重新设计一个不工作的零件，他们会问他为什么他那么特别——他们不需要为其他工厂改变它，为什么要为他改变？
You had asked the question earlier, what's different when you walk into the NUMMI plant? Well, you can see a lot of things different. But the one thing you don't see is the system that supports the NUMMI plant. I don't think, at that time, anybody understood the large nature of this system.
你刚才问了一个问题，走进NUMMI工厂有什么不同？嗯，你可以看到很多不同的地方。但你唯一没看到的是支持NUMMI工厂的系统。我不认为在那个时候有人理解这个系统的广阔性质。
General Motors was a kind of throw it over the wall organization. Each department, we were very compartmentalized, and you design that vehicle, and you'd throw it over the wall to the manufacturing guys.
通用汽车是一种“扔过墙”的组织。每个部门，我们分工非常明确，你设计那辆车，然后把它扔过墙给制造部门的人。
And if something didn't work, or was impossible to assemble, that was their problem.
如果出了什么问题，或者组装不了，那是他们的问题。
And they had to deal with it. And you're in there, you've kind of put your heart and soul into making this whole team concept work, and now you're the messenger that has to go out and say, "Look guys, even though this is the way the system's supposed to work, and these are my issues, I'm not going to be able to solve them, and you're going to have deal with it." And it was destructive, it was detrimental, I mean, no question about it.
他们必须处理它。而你身处其中，你投入了心血让团队概念运作起来，现在你却成了那个去说“嘿伙计们，尽管这是系统应该运作的方式，也是我的问题，但我无法解决它们，你们必须处理它”的信使。这是破坏性的，这是不利的，我的意思是，毫无疑问。
Schaefer says, when he realized how much of the Japanese system happened off the factory floor, it answered something that had never quite made sense to him-- why had Toyota been so open with GM in showing its operations?
Schaefer说，当他意识到日本系统有多少是在车间外发生的时候，它回答了一个他从未完全弄明白的问题——为什么丰田在向通用展示其运营时如此坦诚？
You know, they never prohibited us from walking through the plant, understanding, even asking questions of some of their key people. I've often puzzled over that-- why they did that. And I think they recognized, we were asking all the wrong questions. We didn't understand this bigger picture thing.
你知道，他们从不禁止我们穿过工厂、去理解，甚至去询问他们的一些关键人物。我经常为此感到困惑——为什么他们那样做。我想他们认识到，我们问的都是些错误的问题。我们没理解这幅更大的图景。
All of our questions were focused on the floor, the assembly plant, what's happening on the line. That's not the real issue. The issue is, how do you support that system with all the other functions that have to take place in the organization?
我们所有的问题都集中在车间、装配厂、线上发生了什么。那不是真正的问题。问题是，你如何通过组织中必须发生的所有其他职能来支持那个系统？
Quality at Van Nuys didn't improve, and in 1992, GM shut the plant down for good, leaving 2,600 people without jobs.
范奈斯的质量没有改善，1992年，通用彻底关闭了该工厂，导致2600人失业。
This is what the NUMMI commandos were up against-- entrenched, defensive bureaucracies and workers many of the places they turned. They were not only trying to change the biggest corporation in the world, they were trying to change a corporation that had been essentially a collection of individual car companies-- Cadillac, Oldsmobile, Pontiac, Buick-- each with its own design team, own leadership, and its own way of doing things.
这就是NUMMI突击队员所面临的挑战——根深蒂固、防御性的官僚机构和他们转向的许多地方的工人们。他们不仅试图改变世界上最大的公司，他们试图改变一个本质上是个人汽车公司集合体的公司——凯迪拉克、奥兹莫比尔、庞蒂亚克、别克——每一家都有自己的设计团队、领导层和做事方式。
It's a whole new process, a whole different process than the one they'd grown up with. And it was a huge--
这是一个全新的流程，一个与他们成长过程完全不同的流程。这是一个巨大的——
Dick Fuller was another commando. He ran the information technology division at NUMMI, which used some of the same streamlining concepts employed on the factory floor. He says when GM managers visited NUMMI, instead of trying to figure out how they could benefit from the system, some of them attacked it. Fuller remembers one IT manager who visited from a plant on the East Coast.
Dick Fuller是另一位突击队员。他负责NUMMI的信息技术部门，该部门使用了与工厂车间相同的一些精简概念。他说当通用经理访问NUMMI时，有些人不仅不尝试弄清楚他们如何能从该系统中获益，反而攻击它。Fuller记得一位从东海岸工厂来访的IT经理。
And when he came back, he wrote a report, which if I put a title on it, would say, won't work here. And I think part of that was a threat to him. It was a threat to him to see that that was working so well.
当他回去时，他写了一份报告，如果我给它起个标题，那就是“在这里行不通”。我认为部分原因是这对他构成了威胁。看到它运作得这么好，对他来说是种威胁。
Do you think this guy looked at this and said, well, if this works here and they try to spread it, I'll lose my job?
你认为这个人看着这个说：好吧，如果在这里奏效，他们试图推广它，我就会丢掉工作？
Well, I don't think he was going to lose his job, but he could lose some of his-- you know, he'd probably have to give up half his staff. You know, that's power. People is power in General Motors.
嗯，我不认为他会丢掉工作，但他可能会失去一些……你知道，他可能不得不放弃一半的员工。你知道，那是权力。人就是通用汽车的权力。
Getting all these mini empires to embrace the kinds of radical changes that happened at NUMMI would have taken an almost Stalinesque leadership from above-- a combination of charisma and fury in the corner office. And NUMMI commando Mark Hogan says no one at GM fit that bill.
让所有这些迷你帝国拥抱NUMMI那种激进的变化，需要自上而下近乎斯大林式的领导——一种在办公室角落里魅力与愤怒的结合。NUMMI突击队员Mark Hogan说通用没有人符合那种条件。
I was very convinced that we had to change, and we had to change rapidly, and I think all of us that were NUMMI alums, so to speak, were frustrated at the lack of urgency.
我非常确信我们必须改变，而且必须迅速改变，我想我们这些所谓的NUMMI校友，对缺乏紧迫感感到沮丧。
Did you have those kinds of conversations with people in the '80s back in Detroit?
在80年代回到底特律时，你有过那样的对话吗？
I did.
我有。
What would people say to you?
人们会对你说什么？
Yeah, I think there still wasn't a recognition that the-- the formidability of the competition, particularly from Toyota. I think a lot of people were in denial, or just not willing to recognize it. And even though GM had gone from 50% market share in the early '70s, to mid 30s, it was gradual over time and there wasn't this sense of reaction or urgency that other companies that lost that much market share might have felt.
是的，我认为依然没有意识到……竞争的严峻性，特别是来自丰田的。我认为很多人都在否认，或者只是不愿意承认。尽管通用汽车从70年代初的50%市场份额降到了30多，但那是逐渐发生的，并没有像其他失去那么多市场份额的公司可能感受到的那种反应或紧迫感。
Those exact numbers-- GM went from 47% of the US market in the mid 1970s to 35% a decade later. One reason car execs were in denial was Detroit's insular culture. Yes, unions and management were always at each other's throats, and yes, GM and its suppliers had a destructive relationship that seemed to almost discourage quality, but everyone had settled into comfortable roles in this dysfunctional system and learned to live with it. And in the late 1980s, with their market share in free fall, Jeffrey Liker says they were more apt to blame others than themselves.
那些确切的数字——通用在70年代中期占美国市场的47%，十年后降至35%。汽车高管们否认的一个原因是底特律的封闭文化。是的，工会和管理层总是互相指责，是的，通用及其供应商之间有一种破坏性的关系，似乎几乎在阻碍质量，但每个人都在这个功能失调的系统中安于舒适的角色，学会了忍受它。而在80年代末，随着市场份额自由落体，Jeffrey Liker说他们更倾向于责备别人而不是自己。
I worked with all the big three at the time, automakers, and it was common in all three automakers. They all believed that if the consumers think we have quality problems, it's because Consumer Reports is misleading them, and they're biased toward Toyota. They all believed that Consumer Reports was against them, that there was somewhat of a myth of Japanese quality.
我当时和底特律三大汽车制造商都合作过，这在三大巨头中很常见。他们都认为，如果消费者认为我们有质量问题，那是因为《消费者报告》误导了他们，而且他们偏袒丰田。他们都认为《消费者报告》在针对他们，认为所谓的“日本制造质量”是一个神话。
If all of that wasn't enough to stymie attempts to learn from NUMMI, GM was distracted by other projects-- massive projects. It bought Ross Perot's company, Electronic Data Systems. It bought Hughes Aircraft for $5 billion. It decided the future was robotics. It decided the future was a massive, costly reorganization. It started Saturn, which produced cars that were better marketed than they were built. Then came the 1991 recession-- car sales slumped. Again, Mark Hogan.
如果所有这些还不足以阻碍从NUMMI学习的尝试，通用还被其他项目分散了注意力——大规模项目。它收购了Ross Perot的公司——EDS。它花了50亿美元收购了休斯飞机公司。它决定未来是机器人。它决定未来是一次大规模、昂贵的重组。它启动了土星（Saturn），生产出来的车营销比造工要好。然后是1991年的经济衰退——汽车销售下滑。再次是Mark Hogan。
It was really its first significant wake up call. GM unfortunately had a massive loss, 1992-- General Motors lost more than $20 billion. So I think at that point in time, there was a complete rethinking of the way we ran the company-- that thing's had to change, and they had to change fast.
那真的是它第一个重要的警钟。通用不幸遭遇了大规模损失，1992年——通用汽车损失了超过200亿美元。所以我认为在那一点上，公司对管理方式进行了彻底的反思——事情必须改变，而且必须迅速改变。
It was the largest loss in American corporate history to that time-- $23.5 billion. GM's board of directors responded with what the press called a boardroom blood bath, purging a long list of managers. Jack Smith took over as CEO. He was the executive who'd led the negotiations with Toyota to create NUMMI. He saw NUMMI as a way forward for GM. Mark Hogan and some of the other commandos felt they finally had a champion.
那是当时美国企业史上最大的损失——235亿美元。通用董事会以媒体所称的“董事会血洗”作为回应，清洗了一长串经理。Jack Smith接任CEO。他正是那个领导了与丰田谈判创建NUMMI的高管。他将NUMMI视为通用的前进之路。Mark Hogan和其他突击队员感到他们终于有了一个拥护者。
Jack Smith was installed, and started to rapidly implement the Toyota production system into General Motors.
Jack Smith上任，并开始迅速将丰田生产系统实施到通用汽车中。
Rapidly by GM's standards, which wasn't nearly rapidly enough. Jack Smith declined to talk to me for this story, but he told a reporter a few years ago, "I just wish it had happened a lot faster than it did." Pick your nautical cliche-- reforming General Motors was like turning around a battleship, one manager said. Another compared it to steering the Titanic with a canoe paddle.
以通用的标准来看是“迅速”，但这远不够快。Jack Smith拒绝就此故事接受我的采访，但他几年前告诉一位记者：“我只是希望它发生得比实际情况快得多。”挑选你的航海陈词滥调——改革通用汽车就像掉头战列舰，一位经理说。另一位将其比作用独木舟桨操纵泰坦尼克号。
Jeffrey Liker says the cultural gap between NUMMI and the rest of GM was so vast that even with clear marching orders to change, some of the people running the company didn't know where to begin.
Jeffrey Liker说，NUMMI和通用其他部门之间的文化鸿沟如此之大，以至于即使有明确的变革命令，一些运营公司的人也不知道从何处着手。
There was no vocabulary, even, to explain it. So I remember, one of the GM managers was ordered, from a very senior level-- came from vice president-- to make a GM plant look like NUMMI. And he said, "I want you to go there with cameras and take a picture of every square inch. And whatever you take a picture of, I want it to look like that in our plant. There should be no excuse for why we're different than NUMMI, why our quality is lower, why our productivity isn't as high, because you're going to copy everything you see."
甚至连解释它的词汇都没有。我记得，通用的一位经理接到命令——来自非常高级别，副总裁级别——要让通用工厂看起来像NUMMI。他说：“我要你带着摄像机去那里，拍下每一平方英寸。无论你拍下什么，我要我们的工厂看起来一模一样。为什么我们和NUMMI不同，为什么我们的质量更低，为什么我们的生产效率没那么高，不该有任何借口，因为你要复制你看到的一切。”
Immediately, this guy knew that was crazy. We can't copy employee motivation, we can't copy good relationships between the union and management. That's not something you can copy, and you can't even take a photograph of it.
这位经理立刻就知道这太疯狂了。我们无法复制员工动力，我们无法复制工会和管理层之间的良好关系。那不是你可以复制的东西，甚至连照片都拍不下来。
The first round of changes put andon cords and Japanese style inventory control into the GM plants. But there was no change in the culture. Workers and managers continued their old antagonistic ways. In some of the factories where they installed the andon cord, workers got yelled at when they pulled it. A few plants even cut the cords down.
第一轮变革将安灯绳和日本式的库存控制引入了通用工厂。但文化上没有任何改变。工人和经理继续他们旧有的对抗方式。在一些安装了安灯绳的工厂里，工人拉动它时会遭到训斥。几家工厂甚至把绳子给剪断了。
So the second round of changes included some team concepts. They put together a book explaining how each plant should run, and the reasoning behind it. Geoff Weller was one of the people dispatched in the 1990s to convert the company plant by plant. Weller says some factory managers were receptive, but in the sprawling, decentralized system, the plant manager was still king and ran the factory the way he wanted.
所以第二轮变革引入了一些团队概念。他们编了一本书，解释每家工厂应该如何运作，以及背后的推理。Geoff Weller是90年代被派遣去逐个工厂改造公司的人之一。Weller说一些工厂经理愿意接受，但在庞大、分散的系统中，厂长依然是王，以他想要的方式管理工厂。
We had some tough goes in some of our facilities, where we spent more time trying to convince the plant leadership, versus actually going on and doing the implementation. I would say-- I was asked in one plant to leave, because they were not interested in what I had to sell.
我们在一些设施中遇到了艰难时刻，花了更多时间试图说服工厂领导层，而不是实际去进行实施。我必须说——在一家工厂，我被要求离开，因为他们对我所要推销的东西不感兴趣。
How did he actually ask you to leave? What'd he say?
他是怎么实际叫你离开的？他说了什么？
We're finished, and you can leave.
我们结束了，你可以走了。
And what did you do?
那你做了什么？
I left. Because, you know, I was in his home, so to speak-- his territory, his plant.
我离开了。因为，你知道，我在他的家里，可以这么说——他的领地，他的工厂。
Now, whatever happened to that plant manager who asked you to leave?
那么，那个叫你离开的厂长后来怎么样了？
That plant manager eventually retired.
那位厂长最终退休了。
This may sound like a naive question, but why didn't the CEO pick up the phone and say, you're fired?
这听起来可能是一个幼稚的问题，但为什么CEO不拿起电话说：你被开除了？
Well, it's a big company, and I'm not sure that-- it doesn't work that way.
嗯，这是一家大公司，我不确定——事情不是那样运作的。
Lots of people in GM still didn't see the need to change. By the late 1990s, the company was posting huge profits selling trucks and SUVs, which made the loss in market share seem less urgent. To make real progress, managers had to leave the United States. One overhauled GM Germany. Mark Hogan took over GM Brazil in 1994 to enact NUMMI principles there. In Brazil, he had a big unionized workforce, but he could avoid GM's bureaucracy, its supplier network, and the United Auto Workers.
通用很多人仍然认为没必要改变。到90年代末，公司通过销售卡车和SUV获得了巨额利润，这使得市场份额的流失显得没那么紧迫。要取得真正的进展，经理们必须离开美国。一位改造了通用德国。Mark Hogan于1994年接管了通用巴西，并在那里颁布了NUMMI原则。在巴西，他有一支庞大的工会劳动力，但他可以避开通用的官僚机构、供应商网络和全美汽车工人联合会。
How long did it take you to implement the lessons of NUMMI in Brazil?
你花了多长时间在巴西实施NUMMI的教训？
It took us about 18 to 24 months, which at the time I was quite impatient about. I mean, I wanted it faster.
我们花了大约18到24个月，当时我对此相当不耐烦。我的意思是，我希望更快。
And what did that mean for the bottom line for GM?
这对通用的底线意味着什么？
Well, in that time frame, particularly '94 though '97, GM Brazil was one of the most profitable entities within GM.
嗯，在那段时间，特别是94年到97年，通用巴西是通用内部利润最高的实体之一。
But in America, everyone I talked to said it took about a decade and a half after NUMMI for change to even begin to take hold at GM. By the year 2000, GM finally started to see a generational transformation. Jeffrey Liker says, so many managers had come through NUMMI for training, for a day, or a week, or a year.
但在美国，我交谈过的每个人都说，NUMMI之后，通用花了大约15年时间变革才开始扎根。到2000年，通用终于开始看到一代人的转型。Jeffrey Liker说，太多的经理通过NUMMI接受了培训，无论是为了工作一天、一周还是一年。
Over time, you start to get 10 people, 20 people, 100 people, 300 people, and you now have a critical mass of people in GM who've all been in NUMMI, they've lived it. Now they're managing people and teaching them what they learned, and it snowballs, and suddenly the world is different in GM, and nobody can even tell you exactly why.
随着时间的推移，你开始有了10个人、20个人、100个人、300个人，你现在在通用拥有了一群曾待过NUMMI的关键人群，他们亲身经历了。现在他们在管理别人并教给别人他们学到的东西，这像滚雪球一样，突然间通用内部的世界就不同了，甚至没人能确切告诉你原因。
By the early 2000s, GM had developed a production model with the UAW based on Japanese principles that would go into all of its plants. It was called the global manufacturing system. And although GM quality still lags behind the imports, it's improved a lot. Again, Jeffrey Liker.
到21世纪初，通用已经与UAW开发了一种基于日本原则的生产模式，将推广到所有工厂。它被称为“全球制造系统”。虽然通用的质量仍然落后于进口车，但已经有了很大提升。再次请出Jeffrey Liker。
If you look carefully at the quality of a GM product, and you look with a fine tooth comb, with a magnifying glass, you're going to see a level of quality that you didn't see 15 years ago.
如果你仔细审视通用产品的质量，用细齿梳子、放大镜来看，你会看到15年前看不到的质量水平。
You want to show me for a sec, do you mind? There's one right here.
你想给我展示一下吗？不介意吧？这里就有一辆。
I did my interview with Jeffrey Liker at this year's Detroit Auto Show. And we walked over to the GM exhibit, to the Cadillac SRX, which is a small SUV. Jeffrey pointed to the gap between the door and the car frame, which is supposed to be uniform.
我在今年的底特律车展上采访了Jeffrey Liker。我们走到通用展台，走向凯迪拉克SRX，那是一款小型SUV。Jeffrey指了指门和车架之间的缝隙，那本该是均匀的。
And if we look down here, it looks really good. The gap is about the same between the front and the back door, the surface is very smooth and very uniform.
如果我们看这里，看起来真的不错。前门和后门之间的缝隙差不多，表面非常光滑而且非常均匀。
And 15 years ago, what would that have looked like?
15年前，那看起来会是什么样？
You would see, maybe at the top, it would be more narrow than at the bottom. If you look inside the car and you open the glove box, it falls very gradually down, the way it's supposed to. You close it-- I barely have to touch it and it closes tightly.
你可能会看到，顶部比底部窄。如果你看车内并打开手套箱，它会非常缓慢地落下来，就像它应该的那样。你关上它——我几乎不用触碰它，它就关得很紧。
Precision in all these details makes for a better looking, more reliable car, where things work like they're supposed to. But this improvement didn't come soon enough. Some cars and some plants improved less quickly than others. And while GM was getting better, so were its competitors, leaving it still near the back of the pack.
所有这些细节上的精确度造就了更好看、更可靠的汽车，事情如预期的那样运作。但这种改善来得不够快。有些汽车和有些工厂改进得比其他地方慢。而当通用在变好时，竞争对手也在变好，使其仍然留在末尾梯队。
Well, one of the ironies of GM was that at the moment it went bankrupt, it was probably a better company than it had ever been.
嗯，通用的一大讽刺之处在于，在它破产的那一刻，它可能是它有史以来最好的公司。
That's James Womack, co-author of a seminal book comparing the Toyota and GM production systems, The Machine that Changed the World.
这是James Womack，比较丰田和通用生产系统的奠基之作《改变世界的机器》（The Machine that Changed the World）的合著者。
In the factories, they had really dramatically closed the productivity gap that they had had for many, many years. And on the new products, they have much better quality. So that the company that failed was actually doing better than it had ever done. But it was too late, and that's really sort of hard to forgive-- that if you take 30 years to figure it out, chances are you're going to get run over. And they got run over.
在工厂里，他们确实大幅缩小了多年来一直存在的生产力差距。在新产品上，他们有更好的质量。所以失败的公司实际上比以往任何时候都做得更好。但为时已晚，这真的很难原谅——如果你花30年才弄清楚，很可能你会被碾压。而他们被碾压了。
In the end, what did them in was the 2008 recession. It destroyed the car market, and next year, General Motors became the largest industrial bankruptcy in US history. Its bailout cost taxpayers more than $50 billion. I asked Mark Hogan, the NUMMI commando who went on to run GM's small car division in North America, if GM had adopted NUMMI earlier, could it have really changed all that?
最终，让他们倒下的是2008年的经济衰退。它摧毁了汽车市场，次年，通用汽车成为美国历史上最大的工业破产案。它的救助花费了纳税人超过500亿美元。我问在北美运行通用小型车部门的NUMMI突击队员Mark Hogan，如果通用早点采用NUMMI，这真的能改变这一切吗？
Definitely. I think if General Motors had moved in the late '80s to implement this system across the board, it may very well have saved GM from going into bankruptcy.
绝对。我认为如果通用汽车在80年代末采取行动全面实施该系统，很可能已经把通用从破产中挽救出来。
Explain that.
解释一下。
Well, I just think the productivity and the quality changes that come with that would have been so profound that this ever increasing loss of market share would have been stopped.
嗯，我只是认为伴随而来的生产力和质量变化将非常深刻，这种不断增加的市场份额流失本来会被阻止。
Well, I think they'd have been building a higher quality product.
嗯，我认为他们会制造更高质量的产品。
Again, the UAW's Bruce Lee.
再次是UAW的Bruce Lee。
You know, they sold junk for a while. Just any kind of piece of crap they could roll out there, they did. And they paid a tremendous price for it, and even when they turned the corner in quality, people didn't trust them. They'd say, well, gee, they're building a good car now, why aren't they buying them? Because they don't trust them.
你知道，他们卖了一段时间的垃圾。只要是能推出来的烂摊子，他们就干。他们为此付出了巨大的代价，即使当他们在质量上转弯时，人们也不信任他们。他们会说，嗯，天哪，他们现在在造好车，为什么人们不买？因为他们不信任他们。
But had they adopted and embraced the team concept in an honest way-- we're going to do this-- I think it might have dramatically changed what happened in the American auto industry. There's no question in my mind.
但如果他们以一种诚实的方式采用并拥抱团队概念——我们要做这件事——我认为这可能会彻底改变美国汽车工业发生的事情。我心中毫无疑问。
Of course, quality and reliability weren't the only problems that brought GM down. Executives made other big mistakes. Over the years, General Motors negotiated contracts with the UAW with such generous health care coverage that by 2007, it amounted to more than $1,600 for each vehicle GM produced in North America.
当然，质量和可靠性并不是导致通用倒下的唯一问题。高管们犯了其他重大错误。多年来，通用汽车与UAW谈判达成的健康保险合同非常慷慨，以至于到2007年，通用在北美生产的每辆车都要为此支付超过1600美元。
And initially, some GM executives dismissed hybrid cars, like the Prius, as a publicity stunt. Instead, they bet the company on SUVs and trucks, only to see sales crash when gas hit four bucks a gallon.
而且起初，一些通用高管将普锐斯（Prius）等混合动力车视为炒作噱头。相反，他们把公司押在SUV和卡车上，结果在油价达到每加仑4块钱时看到销量崩盘。
One odd twist to this story-- over the last decade, as GM became more like Toyota, Toyota became a little bit like GM. In 2008, they took over the title from GM of the world's largest car maker. But Toyota executives now say the company did this by making one of GM's old mistakes-- stressing quantity over quality.
这个故事有一个奇怪的转折——在过去十年里，随着通用变得越来越像丰田，丰田也变得有点像通用。2008年，他们从通用手中夺走了全球最大汽车制造商的头衔。但丰田高管现在说，公司是通过犯下通用旧有的一个错误做到这一点的——强调产量优先于质量。
Akio Toyoda is the company's CEO. He's the grandson of the founder, and he cut his teeth at NUMMI. In a congressional hearing last month about Toyota's sudden acceleration problem, he said the company's crucial mistake was growing too fast.
丰田章男（Akio Toyoda）是公司首席执行官。他是创始人的孙子，在NUMMI磨练了自己。在上个月关于丰田汽车突然加速问题的国会听证会上，他说公司最大的错误是扩张太快。
We pursued growth over the speed at which we are able to develop our people and our organization. And I am deeply sorry for any accident that Toyota drivers have experienced.
我们追求增长的速度超过了我们发展人员和组织的能力。对于丰田司机经历的任何事故，我深表歉意。
It was 15 years before GM took the lessons of NUMMI seriously, and they spent the next 10 years slowly implementing what it learned. And all the time, the NUMMI plant kept pumping out vehicles-- 6,000 a week on average, two shifts a day. Toyota got what it wanted out of the deal. A year after starting NUMMI, it began opening other factories around the US using what it had learned in Fremont.
通用花了15年时间才认真对待NUMMI的教训，又花了10年时间缓慢实施所学到的东西。而在此期间，NUMMI工厂一直在生产车辆——平均每周6000辆，每天两班倒。丰田从这笔交易中得到了它想要的。NUMMI开始一年后，它开始利用在弗里蒙特学到的东西在美国各地开设其他工厂。
GM and Toyota continued to run NUMMI together, until 2009 when GM went bankrupt and pulled out, leaving Toyota to run the plant alone. Now Toyota has decided to pull out of the plant. It's their only unionized plant in the United States. Next Thursday, NUMMI will produce its very last car, a Corolla. 4,500 people will lose their jobs. This is the first factory Toyota has shut down since it was founded 73 years ago.
通用和丰田继续共同运营NUMMI，直到2009年通用破产并撤出，留下丰田独自运营该工厂。现在丰田已决定撤出该工厂。这是他们在美国唯一的工会工厂。下周四，NUMMI将生产最后一辆车，一辆卡罗拉。4500人将失去工作。这是丰田73年前成立以来关闭的第一家工厂。
Toyota is not perfect. GM is not perfect. But I think anyone who touched NUMMI will never forget it.
丰田并不完美。通用并不完美。但我认为任何接触过NUMMI的人永远不会忘记它。
One last time, that's John Shook, the first American Toyota hired for NUMMI.
最后一次，这是John Shook，丰田为NUMMI雇佣的第一位美国人。
It does represent something that was special at a point in time. It was a laboratory. My learning curve, it wasn't just a curve, it was a 90 degree right angle. I loved every minute of it. And almost every one, I think you'll talk to, who worked on NUMMI will say the same thing.
它确实代表了一些在特定时间点上很特别的东西。它是一个实验室。我的学习曲线，它不只是一条曲线，它是一个90度的直角。我喜欢其中的每一分钟。我想，你交谈过的每一个在NUMMI工作过的人都会说同样的话。
I'm so fortunate that I ended my career in the auto industry at NUMMI.
我很幸运能在NUMMI结束我在汽车行业的职业生涯。
Rick Madrid retired from the assembly line in 1992.
Rick Madrid于1992年从装配线退休。
I just hate to see the plant close-- oh, that just hurts me. End of an era. It changed my life from being depressed, bored-- and like my son said, it changed my attitude. It changed me all for the better. I really hate to see it go.
我只是讨厌看到工厂关闭——哦，那让我很伤心。一个时代的终结。它改变了我的生活，从抑郁、无聊中解脱出来——就像我儿子说的，它改变了我的态度。它彻底让我变好了。我真的讨厌看到它离开。
I look at cars, and I see a lot of the cars that we built.
我看着汽车，我看到了很多我们造的车。
That's Billy Haggerty, who ended up putting in 18 years at NUMMI without a vacation day. He says just the other day he saw one.
那是Billy Haggerty，他在NUMMI工作了18年，一天假都没休过。他说就在前几天他看到了一辆。
I just seen a-- what was it-- '86, '87 Corolla, pulled in right over around this corner here. I was heading for the bank, and I just looked at it, said, boy, that one's old. I looked down, it was a Corolla. I know we built it, right there. It's still running. It's still kicking. It feels good.
我刚看到一辆——是什么——86、87年的卡罗拉，拐进这边的拐角。我正要去银行，我只是看了一眼，说，男孩，那辆车真老。我看了一眼，是辆卡罗拉。我知道是我们造的，就在那儿。它还在跑。它还很有活力。感觉真好。
This is also NUMMI's legacy. In the end, it's not just a symbol for so many things that went wrong with GM. It's also a really good car plant-- one that turned out nearly 8 million high quality cars and trucks.
这也是NUMMI的遗产。最终，它不仅是通用所犯下许多错误的一个象征，它也是一个非常棒的汽车工厂——它生产了近800万辆高质量的汽车和卡车。
Frank Langfitt is NPR's automotive correspondent.
Frank Langfitt是NPR的汽车记者。
Frank Langfitt's story about NUMMI was produced by me and Brian Reed. NPR's Uri Berliner helped us edit it. Our show today was produced by Lisa Pollak, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Old Japanese TV footage in today's show comes from NHK in Tokyo.
Frank Langfitt关于NUMMI的故事由我和Brian Reed制作。NPR的Uri Berliner帮助我们编辑了它。今天的节目由Lisa Pollak制作，参与人员还有Alex Blumberg、Jane Feltes、Sarah Koenig、Robyn Semien、Alissa Shipp和Nancy Updike。我们的高级制作人是Julie Snyder。今天节目中使用的日本旧电视素材来自东京的NHK。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where our online store is now back up in operation, and where you can find the new update of our iPhone app. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Support for This American Life comes from Kohler. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. I overheard him in the hallway telling someone how surprised he was at the quality of our shows this year.
我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org，我们的在线商店现已恢复运营，你可以在那里找到我们iPhone应用程序的新更新。《This American Life》由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。《This American Life》的支持来自科勒（Kohler）。WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由我们的老板Torey Malatia先生负责。我无意中听到他在走廊告诉别人，他是多么惊讶于我们今年节目的质量。
Because that was not a young workforce. And, you know, they were old, they were fat.
因为那并不是一批年轻的劳动力。而且你知道，他们又老又胖。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass，下周将带着更多《This American Life》的故事回来。